hey guys I'm Ryan right oh hi I'm Jerry
today we're checking out the predator
trailer for Mortal Kombat X DLC the
Russian version it says ver but this is
what I was sent to me several people
sent the Russian version so we speak
Russian we speak a little bit of Russian
vodka uh-uh-uh-uh
stereotyping Russians I love blood and
gore
clearly there's so many videos it's
something of dead watching and when the
time is right
any time now
Oh
Oh
the predator
in your world
maybe two
ah
Oh Jason dude love it I wanna play
that's so hard I love I played this game
several times already
I [ __ ] love playing Mortal Kombat X
adding predator to the mix oh dude that
was so [ __ ] awesome man oh god you
get to do all the cool player stuff you
get the gun you get the camouflage ah
the drama predator is like a perfect I
thought Jason was like that's a
brilliant addition it is but them
predator I'm like that's you know
because he's a creature
hey it's not creature as a hunter you
know he's a dark violent character yeah
we know we can fight and stuff so yeah
he could do the splits '''l and damn
that game is [ __ ] awesome can't wait
to play as a predator to catch predator
love it I love the predator man yeah I
used to have a dream when I was like 9
years old that I could just could the
Crow was also my favorite movie at the
time as well as predator so I used to
want to I would have made a birthday
wish blow my candles saying I want
Brandon Lee to resurrect from the dead
so I can put him in the next predator
movie interesting uh yeah trusting them
none of that happened to which I learned
God is not real I'm kidding
anyway guys thanks for tuning in it
really very strange criteria for things
if you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects you can
check out reasons to Jerry and dank ass
Stubbs on this channel and you can
follow us on Facebook Instagram Twitter
and vine as if we get more followers we
can get even more product placement oh
[ __ ]
Clayton Atkinson Clayton Atkinson hi
Ryan and the rest of the rejects I have
been a sub for a long time
oh good substitute teaching is a great
way to go oh that was like a submissive
like an abundant relationship that could
be that too I watched all the reactions
in the other videos you upload and I
can't stop watching them because you
guys are hilarious to watch and everyone
on your channel is awesome can I have a
shout-out
Clayton Atkinson of course you can have
a shout-out Lee I mean you are a
substitute teacher who is submissive to
the principal I mean you're having a
hard time out there in the school you're
just trying to do your job but then that
principal just comes fine to learn some
kids man dude that sexual harassment you
should not be getting harassed by the
principal granted she has big breasts
she has gray hair but kind of like that
sexy rogue kind of gray hair glasses
just the right amount of wrinkles enough
to really like oh she's past her 40s but
before her 50s maybe in her early 50s
but she clearly has experience and you
know what man keep getting molested it's
awesome